okay so I'm speaking with Doran amate
and you may remember that Dr amate had
invited me a while back to speak at
Ryerson University on a Saturday and
that's been a rather popular YouTube
video and um he's been defending me and
and making comments about free speech on
the Ontario Psychological Association
list sir if that's correct if I got the
details right yes well maybe you could
tell everybody what's been happening
okay sure so uh back in November
um one of our members I won't put out
her name but she wrote uh a piece where
she basically I'll just say what I wrote
um she basically said that um that you
you shouldn't have a forum for
discussing uh what you were supposed to
discuss and that was the um talk that
you were going to have at the University
of Toronto the debate right the debate
um exactly and so she wrote a uh a piece
um and put online and she posted to the
list serve and I essentially wrote uh in
my email to the list Ser I've WR I've
written a number of um comments about
this uh and mostly I've been saying
every time um one of your stories comes
up or another similar story comes up I'm
posting it there saying look this is
what's going on this is not some mad
ramblings this is a legitimate concern
about ideology run a muck and either I
get met by silence or I get people you
know ask me why I'm so angry or why I'm
taking so personally or I get people
emailing me back Channel most the older
people most of the older psychologists
who say we support you completely but
we're afraid to say anything because of
the consequences and what do you think
they're what consequences do you think
they're afraid
of that I don't know I mean I I some of
them work with these colleagues um
others may be trying to get
professorships they're trying to get
tenure and they're afraid that uh these
people who do hold you know positions in
in Academia could hold them down I think
that's the biggest concern it's a
perverse effect of the tenure system
because it tends to silence people
before they have tenure and so then of
course they practice being silent and by
the time they do have tenure if you've
practiced being silent for eight or 10
years then or six years for that matter
then it's going to be pretty hard to
break that habit so so what so what are
they objecting to with regards to your
postings so whenever I post something um
it starts off pretty neutrally and I've
written a long uh message to the Ontario
Psychological Association I sent it to
the president I asked them to read it to
them uh they are convening or they had
convened a meeting uh to deal with this
issue
and um it was very very long and I said
I have not actually done anything wrong
I post links to stories such as yours
like the last Friday want at McMaster um
and then somebody it goes one of two
ways either somebody will um impute my
character or my motives uh recently
somebody had implied that uh your
message is full of hate they actually
use that word someone who has hate in
his heart um you know so and and by
extension myself or they will ask a
question and I will address it but the
for most part they're mischaracterizing
what I'm stating and so I'll simply say
look I did not say that show me where I
said that and more often than not
they're not picking on any specific
issue it's just the the theme because on
the OPA apparently if you're on one side
of an issue it's okay if you occupy a
different position they won't accept it
and so what what do you think has is
going to happen and and what have people
like you said that they've convened an a
so-called emergency meeting about this
issue and so do you have any idea why
it's an emergency and and and what what
they're planning to
do well I think they consider an
emergency because um one of the board
members uh she's the one who wrote that
piece saying that you shouldn't have
this debate and I she took umage uh at a
post that I wrote where you know she's
from o and you know I don't say this
like I'm not being fous she is from oise
and another The onario Institute of the
studies at education for those of you
who don't know and it's a uh you might
if you were feeling charitable you would
recall it regarded as ideologically
possessed right so um so she's from o
and she's the one who wrote the piece
and then somebody else from o wrote what
would anybody any reasonable person
would say it was a um a fair comment
which she was basically trying to say
look can we all just be a bit more
polite in our tone more respectful and
she listed Five Points that we should
all aspire to which I don't disagree
with but the problem is she's also from
o and there's a subtext to the message
which is basically this message is
directed at me so what I did was I wrote
and by the way she posted this after the
president had already shut down the
discussion as soon as he shuts it down I
you know I retract I'm not going to say
anything but the two other people put
postings on and they you know directly
uh you know basically like I said they
they mischaracterized me um and they
look me tried to make me look bad and so
I spoke out and in one of my pieces I I
said to her if you really believe in
what you're saying I said please make
sure you apply this to the people who
are on the other side the ones who were
calling to shut down this discussion I
said and when you say that the president
of the OPA shut down the discussion what
exactly does that mean how does does he
I believe how does he do that and and
and and why did he do it well he sends
out an email and says please this is
getting a bit out of hand will you
please not talk about this that's about
the extent of it and reasonable people
will you know refrain I shouldn't even
say reasonable let's say um people are
trying not to cause conflict will will
stop posting which I've done and they're
concern is I think that the tone gets
out of hand and again I don't think
there's any tone the worst you can say
about my tone is it's blunt uh there's
no name calling it's it's literally
every single time I say show me where I
said this you know or if you you know
you're mischaracterizing that or I say
your argument is irrational sorry it's
it's irrelevant basically uh you know
don't appeal to emotion we're dealing
with facts here let's deal with them and
and you know Lain do you have any
examples of the sort of things that
you've posted that that you could read
your share with us certainly so in one
of the postings so this woman who again
posted something that seemed reasonable
um I basically said to her I said some
I'll just read this couple paragraphs
some members might find my direct
rational logical and fact-based
fact-based messages not only with
respect to the issues themselves but
also with respect to claims made by
those who disagree with me for instance
when I respectfully State please show me
where I said or did this to be rude
offensive or inappropriate which to me
is a gross misuse of such terms however
some of those same people people have
directly stated or implied that I am a
misogynist a transphobe a bigot hateful
reprehensible unreasonable and unwilling
or unable to engage in respectful
discourse the next step is where I got
where things got uh heated I said
moreover and I mentioned the the
colleague I alluded to a few minutes ago
um explicitly stated on this list serve
in November that she did not believe
that Jordan Peterson should have been
given a forum to discuss what any
reasonable person would agree is far
from an unequivocal issue she posted a
link link I post it to an online article
she C co-wrote and this is critical uh
that stated her reasons for what most
objective people should find a
concerning call for censorship of not
only non-hateful ideas but also
scientific investigation and discussion
as well as civil debate about poorly
conceptualized and worded legislation
that could potentially cause unforeseen
harm I wrote that and her response was
she actually posted her response um and
I hadn't heard from her for quite some
time and let me just read it she posted
or an amate I have just as much right to
express my opinion as anyone else I
already put you on notice once but I
will say it again please leave me
alone that's what I think led to the
emergency meeting and you know look at
the the context I have every right I
have just as right much right to express
my opinion as anyone else I agree with
that but why would she be calling for
other people not to have that same right
the hypocrisy is astounding and so what
do you think's going to
happen I really don't know they may ask
me to uh you know to leave the OPA they
may ask me to leave the list serve um
I'm one of the opa's strongest Advocates
I just you know I every time I'm on on
in the media I will mention the work
that they do they do a lot of excellent
work including the president Sil Van Roy
uh he he's done excellent work for
homelessness and for promoting
psychology so the worst they can do is
is try to kick me out I know that um
this member in question was trying to
you know um enact something against me
some you know some censure like more
formal censure it it never happened
aside from a public rebuke um a public
on on what grounds precisely I mean you
you've read some of the things that
you've written I mean why is it that
you're being uh targeted well first for
an emergency meeting which seems a bit
like Overkill but perhaps it isn't but
what is it that they're what is it that
they have on you so to speak that would
result in in censuring of that
sort uh they literally have nothing
because I've not called anybody names um
you know even when I called a member
immature I didn't name them at all so
the worst they can say is the tone might
become a bit hostile but this is what
worries me I again I might be forceful I
might be blunt um I might be repetitive
and verbose but I stick to the facts and
right and the problem is those facts are
on the wrong side of their ideology and
that's what's uh propelling them and
compelling them and and the other thing
is that so I mentioned that he he
receives quote unquote dozens of
complaints from members who this is what
is incredible who are basically saying
that they do not want they can't
tolerate the distress that comes along
with knowing that I'm writing emails to
the list serve and that they might you
know give up their membership this is
the kind of issue that's going on um and
again if you look at my post and I've
written to the OPA and every time
someone criticizes me I specifically
write show me one thing that I've
written that's inappropriate or
offensive and no one's ever called and
they can't and you have a record of all
these postings I presume I have them all
yeah yes and there is there anything in
them that you would be I mean that
you've written that you would be
unwilling to make public assuming that
you could get rid of names and so on
that might identify people is there
anything that would make you
uncomfortable about revealing
publicly the only thing I'd be concerned
about is making sure that we're not
violating some ethical code um you know
which I guess would be portraying the
psychology or psychologist in a negative
light um I don't know if this qualifies
as that I think this is having an honest
discussion about uh person
you presume that you would only be I
would suspect responsible for portraying
psychology in a negative light if if
your portrayal was unfounded from a
factual perspective I I would presume I
mean some reasonable leeway in a in a in
a policy of that sort although the
problem is those things are subject to
interpretation right and that's uh my my
concern um is is that interpretation I I
will see legal councel I don't know if
our coverage uh you know applies to such
a situation um but I will uh ask the
lawyers that we have you know insurance
for and see if this would uh would count
as that I I really don't what's happened
what's happened to you if anything as a
consequence for of Hosting me at Ryerson
I mean that video has got a lot of
attention the only consequence is that
uh people have been thanking me for
being someone who's you know standing
out and saying or standing up and saying
we need to have this discussion uh so
far oh that's good that's good too now
the thing is um my next contract is
coming due at Ryerson I'm a sessional
lecturer I've been teaching there for 15
years um I always get the positions I
apply for because I've taught so so
often I've taught over 160 courses at P
universities Excellence reviews and um
if I find this term that's the first
time ever that I don't get the positions
I apply for that's the consequence we
will find out I I don't think that they
would do that um I think we have a
pretty strong union but I don't have
tenure as we were talking about I don't
have a secure position and you know I've
got a very busy clinical practice but to
stop teaching to be not to be able to
communicate with students who want to
learn who want to you know learn about
critical thinking and being motivated to
challenge ideas that would be you know a
horrible consequence yeah well there's
always YouTube you
know I mean not making light of what's
what's facing you but you know it is
certainly possible if you've got
something to say that that people need
to hear and that actually constitutes
reasonable quality education that in in
a I would not say precisely in a pinch
but it certainly is an alternative and
you have full control over that well it
be very interesting to see what happens
with your with your contract renewal and
we can certainly have another talk at
that time whether it goes badly or
whether it goes well either way so what
do you think's going to happen to you
what do you think's going to happen to
you overall as a consequence of this
what are you afraid of if
anything um I mean the worst that could
happen is if somehow the college decides
that this is you know um this warrants
some kind of heavy sanction that would
be you know if if somehow I lost my
registration over this right right so
yeah so if the if the College of
psychologists got involved in Ontario
rather than just the Ontario
Psychological Association because the
college for for everyone who's listening
the college is the body that regulates
uh clinical psych clinical psychologists
lure in Ontario and to have them make
any action against one of their one of
the one of the licensed psychologists in
Ontario that can be a very very serious
thing that was definitely something that
worried me well it still worries me to
some degree but certainly worried me a
lot back in October and November when
when there were more was more negative
when when the University was responding
negatively for example to what I was
doing and sending me those warning
letters I mean so far nothing nothing
has come of that but um yeah I mean and
that's the only real consequence yes it
is and you know and practically speaking
let's say you know the Ontario ological
Association list serve the OPA list
serve um a lot of people send out
referrals and so if I'm qualified to
deal with one of the cases that they
send it out to you can be guaranteed
that certain people will not uh pass
that referral my way I my practice is
busy enough as it is but you know that
would be a potential consequence this is
why other people might not want to speak
out um you know and again if I'm
applying well it is it is this sort of
thing that that is why people don't want
to speak out and it it also I mean I get
letters hordes of letters dozens of
letters from people who say exactly that
that they're afraid to speak their mind
students and students and people from
all other walks of life who are afraid
to speak their mind because they're
targeted by by people who have
censorship on their mind and Malice in
their hearts I would say and who are
willing to use whatever means necessary
to intimidate people whose opinions they
don't agree with so it's really not good
and the thing is though this is what's
worrying me is that the the OPA the OPA
what I can tell from you know the
comments that people don't see what
you're saying I mean I think they think
you're being hyperbolic uh reactionary
um you know they say show me one case
and now they what the thing is they
always apply it to the transgender issue
and I say please try to see it at a
different level it's not just about
transgenders that's just you know that
was the context uh under which it
happened the actual issue look if this
was about preferred pronouns it would
have died out in about a
week and it hasn't died out at all quite
the contrary and everyone with any sense
knows perfectly well that this is about
far more than than preferred pronouns
that just happened to be the issue dour
so to speak and yes but but I have to
say though that the most recent uh when
I posted the the talks that you had on
Friday uh at McMaster University where
they you know shamefully uh shut you
down um you weren't able to speak when I
posted that you know somebody wrote to
me and again and they they wrote to me
privately and then publicly on the list
serve ask me about why won't he just say
they like they are focusing on that yeah
even though we can clearly see it's a
deeper issue this is the rigidity with
which they they're seeing it's
pretty a react a reaction the reaction
why won't he just say they to viewing
what happened at McMaster University is
a little bit on the peculiar side I
might say so you know it's it's what do
they say swallowing a camel while
straining at a gat I think that's how
that saying goes so
um all right well so is there anything
else that you wanted to talk about
tonight or is that does that basically
cover your concerns and and describe
what's been happening to you reasonably
well I think it does I mean and I'll
I'll look into it and see you know what
I'm able to maybe post publicly uh so
that people can see what kind of
discussions are being had you know I
won't put any names it'll just simply be
you know this this is the the manner in
which we're we're um we're communicating
and the advantage to that would be that
people can judge for themselves right
whatever you know because at the moment
it's sort of he said she said which is
not a great way I mean it's not like I
mean certainly I'm listening to what you
say and believe that you're portraying
it accurately but it's much better for
people to be be able to make that
judgment themselves so that would be
that would be a useful thing to do
assuming that you can do it without
compromising yourself or anyone else in
any unreasonable manner but I I also
don't think it's unreasonable to make
things like this public because well if
you can't make something public you
really have to wonder what's going on
you know if so if there's a a
restriction against sharing what's been
happening on what's more or less a
public it's more or less a public forum
I know that it's it's part of the
Ontario Psychological Association but
it's not exactly private communication
and if you're going to get if you're
going to get in trouble for what you're
posting and it's unreasonable it would
be useful for people to be able to see
that but you can decide that so right
well um well I do want if I sorry Jordan
if I can say one more thing just um
because I do want to be fair to uh to
svan I mean as I alluded to earlier his
concern is that it might be violating
you know some Opa Opa is hosted by the
APA the American Psychological
Association list Ser for whatever reason
and he's concerned that you know that it
might be violating that so for him
shutting things down I have no problem
with that if he's worried about that
reason it's the it's the um I guess the
message coming from the other members
which is essentially they themselves are
saying shut it down because we don't
want to hear it and they think I'm being
just too again too arrogant uh or or
forceful but again that's not the real
reason the real reason is that they
don't like what I have to say and um but
but again I understand the uh you know
the ostensible reason for which uh you
know they're they're shutting down the
discussion I just want to make sure I'm
clear on that I'm not I don't want to
misrepresent that that's what they're
saying yeah yeah well I
mean it's hard to hard to know what to
say about that I mean I appreciate
appreciate what you're saying about it I
mean still seems to me that the whole
point of a list serve is so that people
can communicate their ideas
and and I do believe that we're entering
an age where forceful discussion is
going to be regarded as somehow
oppressive and violent and the problem
is it's very difficult to discuss
anything of importance without a certain
amount of forcefulness which you know is
also directness and bluntness and and
speech that's to the point and we
certainly don't want to interfere with
that and otherwise
well for obvious reasons for obvious
reasons all right well thanks very much
for talking about this and I I guess
I'll know we'll know very soon exactly
how this went and maybe I can talk to
you again when we find out yeah let to
give you an update find out what uh what
they decide